bonjour à toutes et à tous mes chers
concitoyens mesdames et messieurs je
reviens devant vous aujourd'hui avec
plusieurs membres du gouvernement pour
vous présenter l'état de la situation
sanitaire de notre pays et vous annoncer
les mesures que nous avons décidé de
prendre pour en maîtriser l'évolution
comme je vous l'avais dit la semaine
dernière le virus continue de circuler
activement partout en europe
depuis cet automne en réalité tous les
pays européens font face à des vagues
épidémiques qui se succèdent et varie en
intensité au fil des mois selon les
conditions climatiques le respect des
gestes barrières et les mesures de
freinage qui sont mises en place en
france nous avons été l'un des premiers
pays touchés de façon violente par cette
deuxième vague qui a démarré vous le
savez à la mi octobre
cela a été le cas au même moment en
espagne en suisse en belgique en irlande
et au royaume uni puis quelques semaines
plus tard en allemagne en suède et en
italie
face à cette situation tous les pays ont
pris des mesures de restriction pour
freiner l'épidémie
tous ne l'ont pas fait au même moment
tous ne l'ont pas fait avec la même
intensité ni avec la même stratégie dans
la durée la france a fait un double
choix qui nous a distingué de beaucoup
de nos voisins
notre premier choix a été de ne pas
attendre pour décider d'un confinement
adapter ce que nous avons fait dès la
fin octobre et qui a produit un résultat
fort et rapide dès la fin du mois de
novembre
notre deuxième choix a été de ne lever
nos mesures que partiellement et
progressivement en prolongeant c'est
toujours le cas la fermeture de nombreux
établissements recevant du public dans
les domaines de la culture du sport des
loisirs et de l'événementiel mais
également les bars et les restaurants et
en instaurant un couvre-feu à 20h en
vigueur depuis le 15 décembre dernier
d'autres pays ont davantage tardé à agir
et ont rouvert prématurément leur bar où
leur restaurant et en conséquence ont dû
se résoudre à des mesures de confinement
beaucoup plus strictes allant même
jusqu'à la fermeture de l'os de leur
école comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui du
royaume-uni de l'irlande de l'allemagne
de l'italie ou du danemark
je pense sincèrement que notre stratégie
à la fois préventive et réactive
cette stratégie qui reste est cohérente
dans la durée a été la bonne par
ailleurs les premières données dont nous
disposons montrent que nous avons pu
passer les fêtes de fin d'année sans
flambées épidémiques grâce au
comportement responsable qui a été le
vôtre nous rappelant combien la lutte
contre cette épidémie est aussi la
sphère de tous et de chacun
les résultats de notre stratégie nous
place aujourd'hui dans une situation
comparative plus qu'honorable en europe
tant au niveau des taux d'incidence que
des taux de positivité des tests plus
précisément quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui est comment at elle évolué
depuis une semaine
notre situation reste évidemment
préoccupante même si elle s'est
globalement stabilisée au cours des
derniers jours
nous restons sur un plateau élevé avec
une moyenne hebdomadaire qui fluctuent
autour de 16000 contamination par jour
la pression sur nos hôpitaux restent
également à peu près stable mais se
situe elle aussi à un niveau élevé nous
avions hier 24700 sont neuf personnes
hospitalisées de l'aco vide en france
soit 28 personnes de plus que la semaine
dernière
parmi elles deux mille sept cent étaient
hospitalisés en réanimation soit 95 de
plus que jeudi dernier
notre situation je la qualifierais donc
par deux mots maîtrisé par rapport à ce
que l'on observe chez nos voisins mais
fragile car le virus circule encore
activement sur notre territoire est
d'autant plus fragile avec l'élément
nouveau que constitue l'émergence de
nouvelles souches plus contagieuse du
virus
nous surveillons évidemment de très près
ces nouveaux variants et je demande au
ministre des solidarités de la santé
olivier ferrand de vous faire partager
en toute transparence nos éléments de
connaissance qui se sont affinés depuis
la semaine dernière
ce ministre monsieur le premier ministre
la semaine dernière je vous parlais de
ces variants qu'on a identifié qui
peuvent circuler un peu partout dans le
monde et notamment sur le territoire
national je rappelle brièvement ce que
c'est qu'un variant c'est lorsque des
mutations génétiques apparaissent dans
le patrimoine génétique d'un virus c'est
très classique ça arrive d'ailleurs ça
arrive assez souvent dans le coronavirus
la plupart des mutations n'entraîne
aucune conséquence certaines peuvent
potentiellement affaiblir le virus mais
certaines peuvent potentiellement le
renforcer et c'est ce qui nous inquiète
deux variants en particulier ont été
identifiés sur le territoire national le
premier vous le connaissez c'est le
variant d'origine identifiés en tout cas
en angleterre qui s'appelle le voc 2020
ce variant qu'est ce qu'on sait de lui
d'abord qu'il est plus contagieux que le
virus qui circule classiquement en
france de l'ordre de 30 à 70% nous
disent les scientifiques notamment
anglais mais également les scientifiques
internationaux qui ont travaillé sur les
données et ce virus et potentiellement
aussi plus contagieux chez les enfants
en revanche ce virus ne donne pas
davantage de formes graves que le
variant qui circulent traditionnellement
en france et donc c'est plus de cas mais
pas des cas plus graves
par ailleurs encore nous avons toutes
les raisons de penser que ce variance
voc 2020 est sensible au vaccin ce qui
est évidemment une bonne nouvelle en
angleterre l'apparition de ce variant a
provoqué une flambée épidémique
progressive qui a pris environ deux à
quatre mois dans une région du sud de
l'angleterre qui avait été peu touchés
au cours de la première vague et même du
début de la deuxième vague et ce variant
s'est répandu progressivement sur le
territoire jusqu'à devenir majoritaire y
compris d'ailleurs dans la capitale
londonienne
le premier ministre l a dit l'angleterre
est actuellement un mec un confinement
important plus de 1000 morts sont
enregistrés chaque jour dans ce pays et
nous devons donc tout faire pour
empêcher ce variant plus contagieux je
le répète de circuler en france
alors qu'est ce que nous faisons d'abord
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
est mobilisé pour aller traquer ce
variant partout où il peut être et le
professeur bruno lina m'a fait part des
résultats d'une étude qui était conduite
en lien avec l'ensemble des laboratoires
publics et privés et des centres de
recherche du pays
ses conclusions sur les suivantes pour
cent cas de coronavirus diagnostiqués en
france il y en a environ 1 entre 1 et 1
et demi qui correspondrait aux variantes
c'est à dire que chaque jour il y aurait
entre 2 et 300 contaminations nouvelles
de corona virus variant voc 2020 sur le
territoire national
je le disais tout à l'heure le virus est
potentiellement ce variant est
potentiellement plus contagieux chez les
enfants nous avons donc saisi d'une part
le conseil scientifique qui dans ses
recommandations ne propose pas la
fermeture des écoles mais demande une
surveillance renforcée
à l'instar des études menées par le
professeur lina et ses équipes et qui se
poursuivront les semaines à venir
d'autre part la société française de
pédiatrie avant-hier matin a publié un
avis dans lequel elle ne recommande pas
non plus la fermeture des écoles dont
elle considère qu' à ce stade elle
aurait plus de conséquences négatives
pour les enfants qu'elle offrirait de
garantie et elle nous enjoint à
augmenter les dépistages il en sera
question s'agissant de dépistage et des
propositions que nous faisons tout à
l'heure
par ailleurs nous mettons tout en oeuvre
pour empêcher la diffusion de ce virus
avec un contrôle renforcé aux frontières
nous exigeons aussi vous le savez des
tests avant le départ pour toutes les
personnes qui viennent d'angleterre pour
qu'elle puisse rentrer sur le territoire
national et nous renforçons tout ce qui
est contacts racing pourra les détecter
les chaînes de contamination et empêcher
que ce variant se diffuse avantage le
deuxième variante plus rapidement il est
originaire d'afrique du sud
ce variant il s'appelle le variant 501
de la même manière on sait qu'il est
vraisemblablement plus contagieux que le
virus qui circule traditionnellement en
france on a moins de données
scientifiques en revanche sur les
symptômes qu'il peut entraîner mais nous
n'avons pas à ce stade de raison de
penser qu'ils provoquent davantage de
formes graves mais ils restent plus
contagieux et nous devons là aussi le
freiner le ministre en charge de
l'outre-mer sébastien lecornu a fait un
certain nombre d'annoncés visant à
protéger notamment mayotte et la réunion
compte tenu de la proximité géographique
et nous mettons tout en oeuvre sur le
territoire national pour dépister ces
cas il y en a que quelques-uns à ce
stade qu'ils étaient des pistes et pour
vous donner un exemple une patiente
hospitalisée en réanimation dans un état
très grave dans un hôpital
d'ile-de-france a séjourné pendant une
dizaine de jours en mozambique au cours
du mois de décembre dans le cadre d'un
voyage une congrégation religieuse ne le
variant a été identifié chez elle le
contact racing a été activé plusieurs
cas positifs dans son entourage proche
et notamment dans sa famille ont été
identifiés toutes les personnes ont été
isolées et nous travaillons actuellement
pour faire le lien potentiel avec un
autre kloster de ce variant d'origine
sud-africaine de variants 501 dans la
région de nantes avec une personne
également contaminée lors du voyage en
mozambique
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre à ce
stade donc la circulation de cette
souche ou de ces souches variante reste
limité dans notre pays mais vous l'avez
entendu son potentiel de développement
ne doit pas être sous-estimée comme vous
l'avez compris nous devons donc tout
faire pour éviter qu'elles ne
progressent rapidement et du fait de sa
plus grande contagiosité qu'elle ne
finisse par de voeux
la souche dominante comme le royaume-uni
malheureusement en fait l'expérience
cette situation nous conduit donc à
décider de mesures complémentaires en
premier lieu nous allons durcir
fortement les conditions d'entrée sur le
territoire national et renforcer les
contrôles
les contrôles aux frontières à compter
de lundi tous les voyageurs qui
souhaitent venir en france en provenance
d'un pays extérieurs à l'union
européenne quels qu'ils soient devront
effectuer un test avant de partir et il
faudra présenter un test négatif pour
embarquer dans un avion ou un bateau
de plus les personnes concernées devront
s'engager sur l'honneur à s'isoler
pendant sept jours
une fois arrivés en france puis à
refaire un deuxième test pcr à l'issue
pour les rares pays où il n'est pas
possible de réaliser un test sur place
au départ un laissez passer consulaires
pour être accordée par nos ambassades
pour motif impérieux
dans ce cas la personne se fera tester à
son arrivée en france et sera contrainte
de s'isoler sept jours dans un
établissement désigné par l'état pour
les déplacements en provenance d'un pays
de l'union européenne et notamment des
pays comme l'irlande ou le danemark
affrontés à une situation épidémique
difficiles les ministres travailleront à
l'élaboration d'un cadre de coordination
en vue du prochain conseil européen du
21 janvier
ce cadre devra évidemment prévoir des
exceptions concernant les frontaliers
les transporteurs routiers ou encore les
agents des compagnies de transport dans
ce cas dans le cadre de protocoles
sanitaires spécifiques
le ministre chargé de la santé vous l'a
dit nous prenons également des mesures
nouvelles pour nos territoires et
collectivités d'outre-mer la guyane et à
travers celle des antilles doivent être
le plus possible protégé du variant à
risque qui circulent en amazonie le
préfet prendra des mesures de
restriction adapté aux circonstances
locales le contrôle des frontières sera
renforcée
des tests négatifs seront exigés pour
rejoindre les antilles et la montrer que
la métropole comme c'est déjà exigé dans
l'autre sens des informations
préoccupantes indique que le variant à
risque d' afrique du sud serait déjà d'y
signer aux comores des mesures d'urgence
ont donc été prises dès le week end
dernier pour tester en doublant à
l'arrivée des comores et pour
restreindre les déplacements à risque
ces mesures sont tout particulièrement
impérative pour protéger aussi la
réunion département peuplé de huit cent
mille habitants et géographiquement
isolés et de la même manière que pour la
guyane des tests négatifs seront exigés
pour les vols en provenance de mayotte
ou de la réunion vers la métropole
l'ensemble de ces mesures a pour
objectif de réduire drastiquement les
flux transfrontaliers afin de nous
protéger du risque de propagation des
souches variantes
j'ai demandé au ministre de l'intérieur
de prévoir un dispositif de contrôle
pour en garantir le respect sur
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
le couvre-feu s'appliquera à compter de
18 heures à partir de ce samedi et pour
au moins 15 jours
vous le savez cette disposition
s'applique d'ores et déjà dans 25
départements où nous avions observée ces
dernières semaines une progression plus
dynamique qu'ailleurs du nombre de
personnes malades de l'aco vide avec un
niveau d'incidence supérieur à 200 pour
cent mille
pourquoi ce choix il apparaît selon les
données disponibles à ce jour que cette
mesure a une efficacité sanitaires dans
les 15 premiers départements où le
couvre feu a été mis en oeuvre à 18
heures le 2 janvier dernier la hausse du
nombre de nouveaux cas y ait deux voire
trois fois plus faible que dans les
autres départements métropolitains comme
le montre la carte qui s'affiche à
l'écran
dans son dernier avis reçus hier soir
qui sera rendue publique très rapidement
le conseil scientifique a du reste
confirmé l'utilité du couvre-feu dans la
lutte contre la pandémie
nous appliquerons donc cette mesure dans
tout le pays car la situation a évolué
ces derniers jours alors que la reprise
épidémique était concentré fin décembre
sur certains départements la circulation
virale concerne désormais tout le
territoire ainsi plus aucun département
ne présente un taux d'incidence a 7
jours inférieur à l'objectif de 50 pour
cent mille habitants
si d'incidence reste plus élevée dans
l'est du pays là où le couvre-feu
anticipé s'applique déjà c'est désormais
dans l'ouest de la france que la
dynamique est la plus forte
cette mesure de couvre feu obéit à une
logique de freinage préventive elle
permet de graduer notre riposte et
d'essayer d'éviter de passer à des
mesures plus difficile comme nous
l'avons déjà connu à deux reprises
l'année dernière
elle vise à réduire encore davantage les
contacts sociaux sur les heures de fin
de journée tout en permettant le
maintien des activités économiques
éducatives et des déplacements pendant
la journée
cela signifie qu'à partir de samedi 18
heures chacun devra être chez soi
les dérogations très limitées seront les
mêmes que celles actuellement
applicables pour le couvre-feu à 20
heures elles permettent notamment de
revenir du travail ou d'aller chercher
ses enfants à l'école ou à la crèche
mais il ne sera pas possible de sortir
pour des motifs personnels de même sauf
les exceptions liées aux missions de
service public
tous les lieux commerces ou services
recevant du public se renfermer à 18h
dans la mesure où 7 me dans la mesure où
cette disposition va réduire les
horaires d'ouverture des commerces et
afin d'éviter les concentrations des
clients aux heures ouvrables
j'invite tous les établissements qui le
souhaitent à se saisir des possibilités
ouverture supplémentaire sur la pause
déjeuner dans la plupart des
départements des dérogations permettant
l'ouverture des commerces le dimanche
ont pu être accordé suite aux
concertations locales menées par les
préfets et j'invite là aussi les
commerçants pour s'en saisir pour étaler
les ce et nous verrons s'il ya lieu de
prolonger ses dispositions à février
j'ai également demandé au ministre de
l'intérieur et au préfet devait y est
rigoureusement notamment dans les
grandes surfaces commerciales au strict
respect des jauges destinées à limiter
les flux georges prévu dans les
protocoles sanitaires que nous avons
arrêté avec ces professionnels avec ce
renforcement du couvre-feu
nous restons cohérents avec notre
stratégie de réaction graduées et
proportionnées aux risques épidémiques
un effet à l'heure où je vous parle la
situation sanitaire n'exige pas que nous
mettions en place un nouveau confinement
qui constituerait une décision très
lourde dont nous connaissons le coût
humain économique et social je vous
rappelle que lorsque nous avons décidé
le second confinement fin octobre nous
observions de l'ordre de 50 mille
contamination par jour contre eux seize
ou dix sept mille aujourd'hui c'est bien
moins également que les niveaux observés
aujourd'hui dans les pays autour de nous
où l'épidémie flanc la situation
hospitalière étaient également beaucoup
plus tendu mais je veux être
parfaitement clair avec vous si nous
constatons dans les prochains jours une
dégradation épidémique forte nous
serions conduit à décider sans délais
d'un nouveau confinement
car nous devons comme nous n'avons cessé
de le faire depuis le début de cette
crise nous préparer à toute éventualité
avec le président de la république nous
avons souhaité maintenir ouverts les
établissements scolaires et c'est pour
nous je les dis un objectif fondamental
le confinement du printemps dernier à
creuser les inégalités scolaires
et accru les risques de décrochage de
nombreux enfants plusieurs de nos
voisins européens ont fait récemment je
vous le disais tout à l'heure un choix
différent du nôtre
en fermant les écoles ou en repoussant
la rentrée scolaire
c'est le cas de l'allemagne du
royaume-uni du danemark de l'irlande ou
encore de l'italie nous souhaitons tout
faire pour l'éviter
la condition pour pouvoir tenir cette
ligne et que nous renforcions nos
dispositifs sur trois points d'abord le
protocole sanitaire dans les cantines
scolaires sera renforcée nous allons
suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre les
activités physiques et sportives
scolaires et extrascolaires en intérieur
et puis nous allons augmenter encore
notre capacité de dépistage dans les
établissements scolaires avec un
objectif de 300 mille tests par semaine
soit plus d'un million par mois
ces mesures qui vont vous être détaillé
par le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer doivent permettre
de réduire davantage encore les risques
et d'intervenir plus rapidement encore
en cas de circulation du virus au sein
d'un établissement scolaire
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs
comme vous le savez depuis le début de
la crise au mois de mars dernier
nous avons deux critères le premier
c'est assurer la continuité des
apprentissages une continuité la plus
normale possible et en second lieu
protéger au maximum la santé la santé
des élèves la santé des personnels la
santé des français avec l'année que nous
venons de connaître
et comme vient de le rappeler le premier
ministre nous sommes plus que jamais
convaincus qu'il est de première
importance de maintenir ouvertes les
écoles ce n'est pas complètement une
exception française il ya d'autres pays
européens qui maintiennent les écoles
ouvertes mais nous sommes fiers pour
l'année 2020 d'avoir permis que la
france soit un des pays et même le pays
qui a maintenu le plus de jours d'école
pour ses enfants
c'est évidemment essentiel et comme l'a
rappelé encore récemment le conseil
scientifique
c est évidemment essentiel quand on
mesure les avantages et les
inconvénients d'aller à l'école ou de ne
pas aller à l'école de maintenir les
écoles ouvertes car il ya des
conséquences éducatives sociales
psychologiques sanitaire même pour les
enfants de ne pas aller à l'école
nous pouvons donc être collectivement
fier d'atteindre cet objectif nous le
sommes pour les raisons que le premier
ministre vient de dire et nous pouvons
l'être tout simplement parce que les
objectifs sont clairs et je veux
remercier de nouveau les professeurs les
personnels de l'éducation nationale des
collectivités locales qui ont ils nous
ont permis jusqu'à aujourd'hui
d'atteindre cet objectif
cet objectif que nous avons réussi en
2020 réussissons lieu en 2021
pour cela nous devons faire avancer le
curseur du protocole sanitaire dans un
sens un peu plus strictes dans le sens
que vient d'indiquer le premier ministre
et même si au milieu scolaire à ce stade
la circulation du virus reste
relativement maîtrisé nous devons nous
adapter sur certains points afin de
maintenir la protection la plus étendue
possible pour l'ensemble des personnels
et des élèves
cela signifie d'abord le maintien du
fonctionnement en mode hybride
c'est-à-dire en parties en présence en
partie en distance pour les lycées au
delà du 20 janvier
vous savez que vous avez indiqué que
cette mesure pouvait être éventuellement
terminer pour le 20 janvier en réalité
nous la prolongeons
puisque depuis le début du mois de
novembre les deux tiers des lycées sont
rentrés dans ce mode de fonctionnement
et que cela fonctionne au cas par cas en
tenant en tenant compte des réalités
physiques de chaque lycée les lycées qui
le souhaitent pourront donc continuer à
être en mode hybride
et encore une fois nous regardons cela
sur chaque cas particulier dans le
contexte épidémiologique actuelle nous
considérons que ce mode hybride est
efficace mais nous avons une vigilance
particulière pour les élèves de
terminale qui passent le baccalauréat
cette année et donc notre recommandation
est que les élèves de terminale soit le
plus possible en présence dans
l'établissement
s'agissant des collèges à titre
exceptionnel lorsque des établissements
connaissent des contraintes qui sont
dues aux bâtiments et bien il peut y
avoir aussi le mode hybride qui est
choisie cela est autorisé au cas par cas
pour les rectorats en général pour la
classe de 4ème et la classe de troisième
mais ça doit rester exceptionnel puisque
nous savons bien qu'à cet âge là les
élèves s'ils ne sont pas à l'école
peuvent avoir des activités qui sont
éventuellement même plus contaminantes
des mesures aussi son seront prises pour
les cantines scolaires
là aussi nous savons que c'est
éventuellement un maillon faible de
l'organisation puisque c'est le moment
où on enlève son masque le moment aussi
où comme on le sait l'activité
consistant à manger collectivement peut
présenter des risques en termes de
contamination à l'école primaire il n'y
aura pas de brassage possibles lors des
repas entre les classes les élèves d'une
même classe mangeront tous les jours
ensemble et à la même table et si cela
n'était pas possible dans certaines
écoles les temps de prise de repas
seront allongés pour permettre
l'établissement
l'étalement pardon des classes en
cantine en dernier recours on peut avoir
la solution de repas remporté proposés
aux enfants
là aussi c'est au cas par cas que cela
doit se décider dans l'enseignement
secondaire
l'hybridation des lycées lorsqu'elle est
choisie permet de lever normalement la
pression sur le temps des repas
puisqu'il ya moins d'élèves présents
dans l'établissement
et si certains collèges reste en tension
pour organiser le temps de restauration
dans le strict respect des normes
nouvelles dont le détail est évidemment
donné ce soir et aux acteurs de
l'éducation nationale et aux
collectivités locales
et bien dans ce cas les temps de service
serait rallongé ou des repas à emporter
serait proposé en troisième lieu les
cours d'éducation physique et sportive
comme vient de le dire le premier
ministre sont eux aussi modifier toutes
les pratiques que l'on qui sont les
pratiques d'intérieur sont suspendus je
dis bien suspendu ça signifie que tous
souhaitons évidemment d'être en capacité
de les ré ouvrir dès que ce sera
possible
c'est vrai en milieu scolaire c'est vrai
en milieu extra scolaires nous avons été
très actifs pour que les pratiques
sportives puissent reprendre ces
dernières semaines pour les mineures
mais malheureusement nous devons
suspendre pour quelques semaines
probablement ce type d'activité est dans
ton du jeu reste très actif avec roxana
maracineanu avec les milieux sportifs
pour que dans le futur nous puissions ré
ouvrir dès que cela sera possible
enfin en quatrième lieu il a aussi le
premier ministre a commencé à le dire
notre stratégie de test prend un nouveau
tour avec dès le mois de janvier dans
les écoles les collèges et les hippies
c'est une possibilité massive de
déploiement pour plus d'un million de
personnels et des élèves pour accentuer
notre surveillance de la circulation du
virus en milieu scolaire et en
complément de ce que nous faisons déjà
c'est-à-dire le traçage des cas contacts
ce qu'on appelle parfois le contact
racing va évidemment continuer donc nous
le mettons en place avec chaque agence
régionale de santé depuis la rentrée
comme nous vous le montre le graphique
que vous voyez à l'écran et maintenant
nous aurons non seulement ce traçage
donc qui continuera mais aussi la
possibilité pour certains établissements
d'avoir la venue d'une équipe de
dépistage de tous les personnels de tous
les élèves sur place chaque fois qu'il y
aura trois cas de contamination et puis
il y aura aussi l'identification de tous
les personnels lycéens et collégiens qui
se verront donc proposer un test dans
les 48 heures dans ce type d' hypothèse
nous continuerons aussi à fermer des
classes des écoles des collèges des
lycées au cas par cas en lien avec les
autorités de santé locales
chaque fois que un certain nombre de cas
nous conduisent à cette décision
voici monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les mesures qui sont
donc prises en matière scolaire
elles doivent nous permettre de
continuer à accueillir les élèves dans
un cadre protecteur et c'est évidemment
une vigilance de tous compris des
familles dans la façon dont nous
préparons nos enfants à avoir le respect
des gestes barrières au quotidien et à
respecter l'ensemble des nouvelles
règles je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre nous
sommes donc toujours dans cette logique
préventive et cette même logique nous a
conduits dans le cadre du confinement à
suspendre les enseignements en
présentiel dans l'enseignement supérieur
ce passage à 100% d enseignement à
distance a été très difficile à vivre
pour un nombre d'étudiants qui
ressentent pour beaucoup d'entre eux un
profond sentiment d'isolement mais aussi
pour certains de vraies difficultés
psychologiques et ce en dépit des
efforts de leurs enseignants que je
remercie pour assurer la continuité
pédagogique à distance c'est pour le
gouvernement une source de préoccupation
majeure
nous avons déjà arrêté avec la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et dans le
cadre de concertation conduite à la fin
de l'année dernière un certain nombre de
dispositions pour créer de l'emploi pour
les étudiants pour assurer des tutorats
pour aider à leur prise en charge
psychologique lorsque c'est nécessaire
l'effectivité de ces mesures n'est pas
encore complète
et il n'est pas certain qu'elle soit
suffisante nous avons autorisé depuis la
rentrée de janvier que des étudiants en
grande difficulté puissent revenir par
petits groupes de dix quelques heures
par semaine
nous autoriserons à partir de la semaine
du 25 janvier la reprise par demi groupe
des travaux dirigés des élèves de
première année puis si la situation
sanitaire le permet si la situation
sanitaire le permet aux étudiants des
autres niveaux
cette reprise très progressive attendue
par les étudiants mais aussi par leurs
professeurs dont je veux saluer ce soir
l'engagement comme je salue celui de
l'ensemble des personnels de l'éducation
je recevrai demain avec la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur la conférence
des présidents d'université des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
ainsi que les organisations syndicales
étudiantes pour préciser les conditions
et les modalités des évolutions d'un
retour progressif en présentiel
je demande à madame frédéric vidal
ministre chargé de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche de venir
vous présenter le détail de ces
dispositions qu'encore une fois nous
concerterons demain matin
merci monsieur le premier ministre
chacun le sait il a été demandé aux
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
d'assurer la continuité pédagogique dans
l'immense majorité à distance et seul un
nombre très restreint l'enseignement ont
pu se tenir en présentiel et dans des
conditions sanitaires strictes depuis le
début du second confinement cette
situation nous le savons tous est
extrêmement difficile pour les étudiants
qui sont privés de relation humaine
directe avec leurs enseignants mais
aussi avec leur père les étudiants ont
le sentiment que la crise sanitaire a
volé leurs plus beaux moments
je sais aussi l'inquiétude de leurs
familles mais aussi celle de leurs
enseignants et de l'ensemble des
personnels qui chaque jour sont
confrontés à leurs difficultés qu'elles
soient économiques sociales ou
personnels enseignants enseignants
chercheurs personnels des crous et des
établissements recteur tous nous sommes
mobilisés afin d'accompagner au mieux
ses 2,7 millions d'étudiants qui sont
l'avenir de notre pays je sais aussi
l'action complémentaire de nombreuses
collectivités territoriales pour
soutenir les jeunes dans cette période
et je tiens aussi à les en remercier
de nombreux dispositifs ont été mis en
place pour soutenir financièrement les
étudiants depuis le premier jour de la
crise sanitaire
nous poursuivrons ces efforts mais nous
savons qu'ils ne sont pas suffisants les
1600 référents dans les cités
universitaires sont à l'oeuvre pour
soutenir les plus fragiles pour
maintenir du lien social et de
l'accompagnement humain les 20000
tuteurs étudiants seront là pour
soutenir pédagogiquement les étudiants
le nombre de psychologues dans les
universités sera doublée ce semestre et
de nouveaux personnels sociaux
permettront d'accélérer l'accès aux
aides d'urgence délivrée par le réseau
des oeuvres pour tous les étudiants
nous avons pleinement conscience du
découragement qui va croissant chez
certains étudiants et particulièrement
chez ceux qui vit
seul c'est pourquoi nous n'avions pas
fait le choix de la fermeture complète
des établissements lors du second
confinement le maintien des travaux
pratiques ou des formations ne pouvant
pas être délivrée à distance est resté
autorisé une deuxième étape a été mise
en place depuis le 4 janvier dernier
avec l'arrivée progressive dans chaque
établissement des étudiants par groupes
de dix les étudiants les plus fragiles
il s'agit aujourd'hui conformément à ce
que le président de la république avait
annoncé le 4 décembre dernier à ce qui a
été décidé lors du dernier conseil de
défense de franchir une nouvelle étape
afin que le second semestre puisse se
dérouler dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
en attendant que la campagne de
vaccination nous permettent de retrouver
une vie normale sur les campus
universitaires dans les écoles et les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
nous devons permettre aux étudiants de
renouer le contact en présentiel avec
leurs enseignants il est impératif que
nous puissions progressivement tracer
ensemble ce chemin qui nous permettra de
passer d'une majorité d'enseignement en
distance y ait là une majorité
d'enseignement en présentiel
conformément à ce que vient d'annoncer
le premier ministre et dans le respect
du calendrier universitaire dès la
semaine du 25 janvier les travaux
dirigés pourront donc reprendre en
demi-groupe pour les étudiants de
première année c'est une étape sur ce
chemin avant de pouvoir réintégrer
davantage d'étudiants dès demain avec
les conférence des présidents
d'université des directeurs
d'établissements ainsi qu'avec les
organisations étudiantes
nous allons construire les conditions
permettant cette reprise échelonnée des
enseignements dans le supérieur
les protocoles d'accueil devront
prévenir le brassage des étudiants
garantir les règles de distanciation
ils devront éviter que les étudiants
restent sur site pour les pauses
méridiennes
en lien avec les équipes du ministère
des solidarités la santé dépistage
individuel ou collectif seront déployés
des tests antigénique seront mis à la
disposition des services de santé
universitaire dont je salue l'action au
quotidien et tout ceci sera fait en
partenariat étroit avec les rectorats et
les autorités de santé pour nous
permettre de surveiller l'évolution de
l'épidémie dans les établissements je me
réjouis vraiment que les liens humains
si important pour l'acquisition des
connaissances comme pour la construction
personnelle et psychologique des
étudiants puissent se renouer au cours
des prochains jours et des prochaines
semaines
je crois qu'il en va de l'avenir de
notre jeunesse
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la ministre mesdames et messieurs les
les mesures que je viens de vous
annoncer mesure jamais parfaitement
conscient feu difficile et qui résultent
de du maintien au niveau de cette
pandémie nous conduisent en réalité plus
que jamais à consacrer toutes nos forces
à la campagne vaccinale cette campagne
vaccinale qui a démarré en ce début
d'année et qui nous offre enfin un motif
tangible d'espoir une vraie perspective
de sortie de crise la première
vaccination a eu lieu dans notre pays le
27 décembre lors de la première semaine
de janvier
cent mille personnes ont été vaccinées
au cours de cette deuxième qui n'est pas
terminé nous pensons que 250 mille
autres le seront nous avons vacciné hier
57 mille personnes en une seule journée
cette montée en puissance va se
poursuivre encore la semaine prochaine
notamment dans les ehpad et en ouvrant
dès lundi prochain la vaccination à
toutes les personnes âgées de plus de 75
ans à la fin du mois de janvier nous
serons au dessus du million de personnes
vaccinées qui était notre objectif
initial
ce résultat ne s'explique pas parce que
nous aurions reçu plus de vaccins mais
parce que nous avons espacées d'une
semaine les chances de là
deuxième injection et que nous observons
beaucoup moins de pertes dans
l'utilisation des doses reçues
j'entends encore des commentateurs
s'étonner de ce que nous ne le vaccinons
pas tout de suite tout le monde quel que
soit l'âge ou la situation de santé je
veux une nouvelle fois rappeler ici un
élément fondamental
ces nouveaux vaccins ont une double
efficacité ils limitent la transmission
et surtout surtout ils préviennent la
personne atteinte de développer une
forme grave de la maladie
or nous savons que l'immense majorité de
celles et ceux qui meurent ou qui sont
hospitalisés pour coville sont des
personnes âgées ou atteintes d'une
pathologie chronique
ce sont donc eux qu'il faut protéger les
premiers c'est une question éthique
c'est aussi une question d'efficacité
car plus nous les vaccineront vite plus
vite nos hôpitaux seront mis à l'abri
des risques de surcharge et plus vite
nous pourrons lever les mesures de
restrictions qui pèsent sur toute la
population conformément à notre
stratégie de priorisation des plus
fragiles et un accord avec les autorités
scientifiques et les associations de
patients
j'ai décidé d'ouvrir dès lundi 18
janvier également la vaccination aux
personnes quel que soit leur âge
présentant une des pathologies
conduisant à un très haut risque de
formes graves de la maladie
plus de 700 centres de vaccination
seront ouverts lundi grâce à la
mobilisation conjointe de l'état des
élus locaux et des professionnels de
santé
je tiens à remercier l'ensemble des
personnes qui contribuent à l'hôpital et
en ville ce que j'ai personnellement
constaté avec le ministre olivier veyrat
samedi à tarbes ou encore ceux ce matin
à metz je salue je salue les équipes de
l'hôpital de metz c'est un petit clin
d'oeil pour leur formule 1
le mobilisation et ce mouvement at est à
la fois de cette forte mobilisation et
de la mise en place de dispositifs
efficaces
à compter de demain matin 8 heures il
sera possible de prendre rendez vous par
internet ou par téléphone auprès de ces
centres je veux insister sur le fait que
la vaccination de ces premiers publics
prioritaires va nécessairement prendre
plusieurs semaines
tout le monde ne pourra pas trouver un
rendez-vous immédiatement il faudra être
patient et comprendre que si nous
ouvrons de nombreux centres tout de
suite
nous dépendons des livraisons de vaccins
qui elle même dépend du rythme de
production des laboratoires tous les
pays du monde sont logés à la même
enseigne
tous les pays européens ont passé
ensemble des commandes massives au
prorata de leur population
la production des vaccins déjà autorisé
montent en charge d'autres vaccins
pourraient être également autorisé par
les autorités scientifiques européennes
dans les prochaines semaines je demande
au ministre des solidarités et de la
santé de vous faire un point plus
détaillées sur le déroulement de notre
stratégie vaccinale et sur ses
perspectives
olivier veyrat vous êtes de plus en plus
favorable dans toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion à la vaccination et vous avez
raison puisque le vaccin est un moyen de
vous protéger et demain j'espère de
pouvoir protéger vos proches et pour
tous de retrouver une vie tel que nous
l'avions avant que la pandémie ne
démarre il y a un an vous l'avez dit
monsieur premier ministre deux cent
quarante sept mille personnes étaient
vaccinées hier soir donc nous avons vous
le savez simplifiée amplifiés et
accélérés 190 mille professionnels de
santé ont déjà été vaccinées hier nous
atteindrons je n'ai pas encore les
chiffres du jour mais nous ne serons pas
loin des 300 milles selon toute
vraisemblance et à partir de la semaine
prochaine la campagne de vaccination
dans les ehpad les établissements pour
personnes âgées va prendre de l'ampleur
et en l'espace de trois semaines nous
comptons vacciner plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes parmi les plus
vulnérables du pays et je me joins aux
remerciements qui ont été formulées par
le premier ministre pour toutes celles
et ceux qui s'activent partout sur le
territoire national dans les plusieurs
centaines de centres qui sont déjà
opérationnels donc à partir de lundi
nous ouvrons la vaccination c'est vrai
aux personnes âgées de 75 ans et plus et
sur avis de la haute autorité de santé
mais également du professeur alain
fischer pourront également être vaccinés
à partir de lundi quelques 800 mille
personnes qui sont atteintes de maladie
particulièrement grave et qui les
rendent très vulnérables au risque de
formes graves de lakovic 19
parmi ces maladies il y à l'insuffisance
rénale chronique sévère un cancer sous
traitement les transplanter d'organes
mais également les personnes atteintes
de trisomie
pour toutes ces personnes il leur faudra
consulter leur médecin leur médecin
traitant qui leur fera une ordonnance
qui leur permettra de rejoindre donc les
personnes qui sont appelées à se faire
vacciner c'est à dire les personnes de
75 ans et plus au total ce sont 6 4
millions de français qui sont appelées à
se faire vacciner à partir de lundi
alors comment prendre rendez vous trois
moyens un moyen que je vous recommande
chaleureusement c'est de contacter le
centre de vaccination le plus proche de
chez vous vous pouvez trouver son
adresse son numéro de téléphone moyen de
le contacter auprès de votre mairie de
votre médecin de votre pharmacien
près de vos amis ou même dans la presse
locale vous avez deux autres moyens pour
prendre rendez vous le premier c'est le
site internet www.sante.dz qui vous
permet de prendre rendez vous
directement en ligne pour un créneau de
vaccination dans le centre le plus
proche de chez vous si vous n'êtes pas
en mesure de le faire par vous même vous
pouvez évidemment vous faire aider par
un proche et enfin vous avez la
possibilité d'appeler un numéro de
téléphone national c'est le 0 800 00 910
0 800 00 910 un numéro de téléphone qui
sera activé à partir de demain matin 8
heures il sera ensuite ouvert 7 jours
sur 7 de 6 heures du matin à 22 heures
pour la métropole et les territoires
ultra marins bien sûr et ce numéro de
téléphone vous orientera directement
vers les plateformes téléphoniques du
centre de vaccination le plus proche de
chez vous quelques informations
importantes
d'abord les vaccinations se feront
progressivement au rythme de nos
livraisons comme c'est le cas en france
en europe mais également partout dans le
monde
à la fin du mois de février nous aurons
les doses pour vacciner 2.5 millions de
français et si certains vaccins dont
nous espérons la validation dans les
prochaines semaines venait d'être
effectivement validé eh bien nous
pourrions disposer au total de 4
millions de doses de vaccins
voyez donc il y a 6 4 millions de
personnes de plus qui sont appelées à se
faire vacciner et que d'ici la fin du
mois de février nous n'aurons pas encore
toutes les doses pour vacciner tout le
monde mais je vous le dis si ça prend du
temps plusieurs semaines soyez rassurés
en définitive vous serez vacciner si en
dépit de tous les efforts qui ont été
faits par toutes les équipes techniques
je salue notamment cédric au secrétaire
d'état en charge du numérique qui fait
beaucoup le site si le site internet
aussi les lignes téléphoniques devaient
être surchargé ce ne serait évidemment
que temporaire pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée alors même que nous ne pouvions
pas encore prendre rendez vous sur le
site sante.fr nous enregistrions près de
huit mille connexions toutes les
secondes sur le site internet ce matin
le site est renforcée aujourd'hui il
était mis à jour et demain matin et ce
soir et demain matin il sera pleinement
opérationnel je me réjouis que vous
soyez nombreux à vouloir vous faire
vacciner et je vous le redis toutes les
personnes qui souhaitent être vaccinés
le seront mais cela prendra plusieurs
semaines chaque centre de vaccination
sur le territoire national il y en a je
le dis plusieurs centaines chaque centre
c'est précisément de combien de doses de
vaccins ils disposent et combien de
combien de doses de vaccin il disposera
pour les quatre semaines à venir
chaque centre est donc en capacité de
donner des rendez vous pour les quatre
semaines à venir et nous avons insisté
de manière assez strictes pour que ces
centres évidemment ne prévoit pas ne
prévoit pas plus de créneaux de rendez
vous qui ne dispose de doses afin
d'éviter de convoquer des personnes de
façon innée
il donc tout est mis en place pour
commencer cette vaccination grand public
à partir de lundi à nouveau un grand
merci à tous les soignants des hôpitaux
publics notamment mais également privé
des libéraux des élus et des personnels
administratifs des ars des préfectures
qui sont des milliers à travailler
toutes les semaines tous les jours pour
pouvoir organiser cette campagne de
vaccination dans les meilleures
conditions
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez compris mesdames et messieurs
l'accès à la vaccination nous permet
d'espérer une sortie progressive de
cette crise d'ici l'été prochain
d'ici là le virus évidemment et continue
à produire ces ses ravages et ses dégâts
et nous conduisent donc à prendre comme
aujourd'hui encore des mesures destinées
à son freinage et à l'après nage de sa
propagation
cela fait bientôt une année que nous qui
sommes contraints et je sais
parfaitement tout ce que cela peut
représenter pour toutes celles et ceux
qui en subissent les effets dans leur
vie quotidienne et plus encore dans leur
activité professionnelle
mais vous le savez aussi la france a
fait ce qu'il fallait pour venir en aide
à tous ceux là aux acteurs culturels aux
entreprises aux salariés et aux
indépendants au commerce aux hôtels
cafés restaurants professionnels de la
montagne association au monde sportif
professionnel de l'événementiel et à
tous ceux qui ont subi et qui subsistent
encore l'impact de cette crise nos
mesures de soutien ont été mises en
place rapidement au printemps dernier
nous les avons renforcé et adapté au fur
et à mesure de la crise
au cours des derniers mois avec un
dialogue constant avec tous les secteurs
concernés
ces dispositifs fonctionnent et ont
permis de sauver des millions
d'entreprises d'emplois
je sais combien tout le monde voudrait
plus de visibilité sur la suite
quand est-ce que nous pourrons rouvrir
ce qui aujourd'hui ne l'est pas quand
est-ce que l'activité économique pourra
reprendre durablement
toutes ces questions sont évidemment
légitime
difficile compte tenu des incertitudes
de répondre à ces questions de manière
précise même si l'identification de
perspectives et d'échéance constitue une
priorité en lien avec les représentants
des secteurs concernés ce sur quoi je
m'engage avec certitude c'est que nous
maintiendrons nos dispositifs de soutien
aussi longtemps que cela sera nécessaire
le président de la république l'a encore
répété nous devons entendre le besoin de
sécurité de stabilité que nous expriment
les acteurs économiques et sociaux
nous ne vont pas ajouter de
l'incertitude économique à l'incertitude
sanitaires nous devons rester à leur
écoute et savoir ajuster encore lorsque
c'est juste et nécessaire
tous nos dispositifs d aide c'est le
sens des présentations qui vont vous
être maintenant faites par les ministres
qui au quotidien au quotidien sont à
l'écouté de leurs secteurs
professionnels pour adapter nos
dispositifs dead est apte accompagnement
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la relance elisabeth
bornes en charge du travail et de
l'emploi et roselyne bachelot ministre
de la culture je les invite chacun à
leur tour à venir présenter la situation
à ce jour des différents secteurs
d'activité dont ils ont la charge et
surtout les conditions de prorogation et
d'adaptation des dispositifs
d'accompagnement qui ont été mis en
place monsieur mise économie
merci monsieur le premier ministre a
comme vous venez de l'indiquer monsieur
le premier ministre
plus les mesures de sécurité sanitaire
dur que nous sommes obligés de les
renforcer
plus elles sont difficiles à supporter
pour les entrepreneurs pour les artisans
pour les commerçants pour les
indépendants qui ne souhaiteraient
qu'une seule chose travailler et
travailler le plus rapidement possible
dans des conditions normales avec le
premier ministre avec le président de la
république nous avons une conscience
aiguë de la lassitude de la colère du
désespoir parfois de toutes ces
professions
nous ne pouvons pas donner de visibilité
sur un calendrier de sortie de crise
sanitaire
mais nous voulons donner de la
visibilité sur notre soutien économique
ce soutien économique il a été immédiat
depuis le premier jour de la crise il a
été massif
il a été comparable tout ce qui se fait
dans les autres pays européens
et comme vient de l'indiquer jean castex
il durera aussi longtemps que cela sera
nécessaire et nous l'adapterons à la
réalité de la situation de chacun
puisque nous sommes en discussion
quotidiennement avec l'ensemble des
professions qui sont touchés par ces
mesures de restrictions sanitaires
le pilier de ce soutien économique
restera le fonds de solidarité
ce fonds de solidarité je veux dire tout
de suite qu'un nouveau formulaire pour
les aides de décembre sera disponible
demain vendredi 15 janvier tous ceux qui
ont accès ce fonds de solidarité
pourront s'inscrire ce nouveau
formulaire et toucher les aides au début
de la semaine prochaine je sais combien
est important d'avoir un calendrier
précis de versement des aides
économiques pour les acteurs qui sont
concernés à la demande du président de
la république et du premier ministre
nous introduirons trois changements
majeurs sur ce fonds de solidarité et
nous ferons un effort particulier le
premier changement concerne le produit
de la vente à emporter et de livraison à
domicile
nous avons décidé pour tous ses produits
de la vente à emporter des livraisons à
domicile qui concerne en particulier les
restaurateurs qui ne sera pas intégrée
dans le chiffre d'affaires de référence
pour le calcul du montant de l'aide du
fonds de solidarité ce sera uniquement
pour les restaurateurs il n'y aura
aucune déduction
cette facilité la vaudra à partir du
mois de décembre l'année dernière donc à
partir du mois de décembre 2020 cela
restera la règle pour les mois à venir
par conséquent tout ce qui sera touchée
par les restaurateurs en matière de
produits devant emporter et de livraison
à domicile je salue les efforts
d'imagination qui ont été faits par les
restaurateurs dans ce domaine là ce sera
pour eux non déductible du fonds
solidarité applicable à compter du mois
de décembre de l'année passée
le deuxième changement c'est que les
fournisseurs de ce secteur des cafés de
la restauration
ceux qui sont en première ligne mais qui
ne sont pas fermées je pense au commerce
de gros de poisson je pense aux hôtels
je pense aux brasseurs au blanchisseurs
au torréfacteur hongrois aujourd'hui et
ned qui est plafonné à 10000 euros
ça n'est pas suffisant nous avons donc
décidé que dès lors qu'il perdait 70 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires
ils auraient droit cette fois ci à une
aide en pourcentage leurs chiffres
d'affaires ils pourront choisir cette
modalité là jusqu'à 20% de leur chiffre
d'affaires
dans la limite de 200 mille euros il
passe donc d'une aide forfaitaire à
10000 euros à une possibilité d'avoir
accès à une aide en pourcentage de leur
chiffre d'affaires
jusqu'à un montant pouvant aller jusqu'à
deux cent mille euros cela sera
applicable pour le mois de décembre là
aussi pour couvrir le mois de décembre
passé qui était particulièrement
difficile pour ses fournisseurs et il
n'y aura pas de limite de nombre de
salariés alors qu'auparavant il y avait
une limite en nombre de salariés à 50
salariés tous les entrepreneurs
fournisseurs seront donc concernés il
suffit d'avoir perdu 70% de son chiffre
d'affaires il n'y a plus de plafond en
nombre de salariés et l'aide pourra
aller jusqu'à deux cent mille euros par
mois le troisième changement concerne
les coûts fixes
parce que nous avons parfaitement
conscience que pour beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs le poids des coûts fixes
des charges fixes je pense en
particulier aux loyers est absolument
insupportable
dans cette période de fermeture de
limitation de leurs activités ça
concerne bien entendu des structures
importantes je pense aux chaînes
d'hôtels je pense aux restaurateurs qui
ont plusieurs restos rendre dans une
même ville
je pense aux activités indoor je pense
au bowling je pense aux salles de sport
toutes ces activités là ont besoin que
leurs charges fixes soient couvertes
nous prendrons donc en charge les coûts
fixes de toutes les entreprises de ces
secteurs
dès lors qu'elles réalisent plus de 1
million de chiffre d'affaires par mois
et nous allons travailler que les
parlementaires aux meilleures façons de
baisser ce seuil de 1 million d'euros
qui je sais peut être pénalisant pour un
certain nombre de petites structures
très spécifiques
cette aide exceptionnelle pour les
charges fixes s'ajoutera à l'aide du
fonds de solidarité
elle sera plafonnée dans un premier
temps à une aide de trois millions
d'euros c'est la négociation que nous
avons conduite avec la commission
européenne pour la période de janvier à
juin 2021
mais c'est un point de départ c'est 3
millions d'euros et nous allons
continuer à négocier avec la commission
européenne pour voir si nous ne pourrons
pas relever encore ce plafond de 3
millions d'euros de prises en charges
les charges fixes pour les entreprises
de taille plus importante qui ont des
charges fixes très lourde et qui n'ont
en face pas de revenus ou que des
revenus très limité c'est 2,3 cm
changements que nous avons voulu
introduire avec le président de la
république et le premier ministre
enfin nous allons faire un effort
particulier un effort particulier pour
nos amis viticulteurs les viticulteurs
sont injustement touchées par les
sanctions américaines au titre du
conflit airbus boeing
nous allons évidemment faire le maximum
avec le ministre en charge du commerce
extérieur
heures franck riester pour essayer de
trouver une solution avec nos amis
américains ce conflit airbus boeing mais
cela prendra plusieurs semaines
et en attendant les vins tranquilles et
cognac ont des tarifs de 25 %
supplémentaires qui pénalise
terriblement les exportations de vins et
de spiritueux vers les états unis qui
sont le premier marché de destination de
ses vins et spiritueux ils pourront donc
ces viticulteurs bénéficier d'une aide
jusqu'à deux cent mille euros par mois
dès lors qu'ils perdent 50 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires et pourront également
bénéficier de la prise en charge des
coûts fixes avec le plafond de 3
millions d'euros pour les grosses
structures dont je viens de parler
j'espère que cela aidera les et
viticulteur à passer ces moments
difficiles et je veux leur redire que
nous poursuivons tous notre travail pour
obtenir aussi le soutien de la
commission européenne avec un fonds de
compensation est évidemment le règlement
définitif du conflit commercial avec les
états unis
le deuxième volet dette que nous voulons
apporter concernent les prêts pour
passer cette période particulièrement
difficile des centaines de milliers
d'entreprises près de 650 milles ont
contracté des prêts garantis par l'état
et je sais que certains voient approcher
avec beaucoup d'inquiétude
la première échéance de remboursement de
leur capital si l'on souscrit un prêt en
mars 2020 et se disant mars 2021 il faut
commencer à rembourser ou en mai 2020 en
mai 2021 il faudra commencer à
rembourser la première échéance
nous allons donc permettre à toutes les
entreprises qui le souhaitent de
différer d'une année supplémentaire
le remboursement de leurs prêts garantis
par l'état si elle souhaite le
rembourser au 1er mars 2022 au lieu du
1er mars 2021
elles pourront le faire ce différé de
remboursement d'un an supplémentaire du
prêt garanti par l'état est de droit
pour toutes les entreprises quelle que
soit leur secteur d'activité
et quelle que soit leur taille et je
tiens vraiment à remercier la fédération
bancaire française avec laquelle nous
travaillons en parfaite intelligence
depuis le début
de cette crise pour le sens des
responsabilités dont elle a fait preuve
et pour cette solidarité qui est la
seule manière pour nous tous de sortir
de cette crise économique
j'invite évidemment toutes les
entreprises à contacter dès maintenant
leur banquier leur agence bancaire pour
définir les modalités d'amortissement de
leurs prêts en tenant compte de ce
différé d'amortissement supplémentaire
qui leur est accordé je sais également
qu'au delà des prêts garantis par l'état
d'autres prêts ont été contractés qui ne
sont pas dans le champ des prêts
garantis par l'état et qui sont aussi un
motif d'inquiétude pour beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs à ma demande
les banques se sont donc engagés à
examiner favorablement toute demande de
moratoire ou de report d'échéances pour
les entreprises qui sont les plus
touchés par la crise sur une base
personnalisés j'avais donc là aussi
toutes les entreprises qui sont en
grande difficulté qui souhaiteraient
pouvoir bénéficier de ce moratoire ou ce
report d'échéance sur un prêt qui n'est
pas un prêt garanti par l'état à faire
la démarche auprès de leur agence
bancaire
troisième élément de soutien les
cotisations sociales
je veux simplement confirmer que nous
maintiendrons en janvier les
exonérations de cotisations sociales et
les aide au paiement des cotisations
sociales qui ont été mises en place en
décembre
l'objectif est simple zéro charges
sociales pour les entreprises qui sont
fermées ou qui sont lourdement pénalisés
dans les secteurs liés à l'hôtellerie le
café la restauration le sport le monde
la culture ou le monde événementiel
quand je recevrai très prochainement car
je sais qu'ils sont une inquiétude toute
particulière étant donné l'absence de
perspectives de ventes e enfin le
dernier point céder différé
d'amortissement
c'est un point qui peut paraître
technique pet est très important pour
les hôtels pour les restaurateurs
il sera possible de différer
l'amortissement comptable des biens qui
ont été sous utilisés en 2020 afin de
soulager des comptes des entreprises et
de préserver leurs fonds propres pour
les hôtels pour les remontées mécaniques
pour les discothèques pour les salles de
sport pour les résidences de tourisme
pour les restaurants ce différé
d'amortissement
doit être un vrai soulagement pour leur
trésorerie
l'ensemble de ces mesures que nous avons
prises avec le président de la
république et le premier ministre
représente un coût de 4 milliards
d'euros environ par mois
c'est dire l'importance du soutien
économique que nous avons apportées
depuis le début de cette crise et que
nous continuerons à porter jusqu'à ce
que la crise sanitaire soit derrière
nous enfin je voudrais terminer en
signalant que au delà de ce soutien
économique nous voulons aussi avec jean
castex préparer l'avenir économique et
je voudrais insister sur les trois
enjeux stratégiques qui devront nous
permettre de construire l'avenir
le premier c'est évidemment permettre
aux français de consommer dans
l'économie française et d'investir dans
l'économie française
les 100 milliards d'euros qu'ils ont
épargné pendant cette crise cela suppose
la confiance la lisibilité de notre
stratégie économique et financière est
bien entendu une garantie que nous
n'avons cessé de donner avec le présent
la république et le premier ministre
nous n'augmenterons pas les impôts des
français et nous continuerons à engager
les baisses d'impôts que nous avons
engagé depuis plusieurs années sur
l'impôt ces sociétés pour les
entreprises les impôts production sur
l'impôt sur le revenu ou sur les taxes
d'habitation c'est un choix stratégique
dont dépend la confiance économique des
ménages et leur capacité à consommer ces
100 milliards d'euros le deuxième enjeu
stratégique que nous l'a demandé le
président de la république hier c'est
d'engager sans délai la relance 100
milliards d'euros supplémentaires qui
devront être décaissés dans les
meilleurs délais nous heavy ion avec le
premier ministre
de manière quotidienne afin de nous
assurer que la relance économique
démarre dans les territoires enfin le
dernier enjeu stratégique
au delà de la consommation de la relance
économique
c'est les fonds propres des entreprises
ces fonds propres des entreprises sont
absolument décisif pour qu'elle
investisse qu'elles innovent qu'elles
créent de la richesse et qu'elle crée de
l'emploi
ces fonds propres opposeront largement
sur la mise à disposition de prêts
participatifs pour un montant d'environ
20 milliards d'euros et nous
sisteron la garantie de l'état au volume
de ses prêts participatifs
je préciserai le 28 janvier prochain les
modalités de ces prêts participatifs
soutenu par l'état
dès que nous aurons fini la négociation
avec la commission européenne sur ce
sujet je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
lisabeth bornes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur premier ministre depuis
le début de la crise le gouvernement
soutient les entreprises et protège les
emplois en prenant en charge la
rémunération des salariés avec
l'activité partielle en novembre ce sont
près de 3 millions de salariés qui
étaient en activité partielle après
avoir été près de 9 millions lors du 1er
confinement cet outil puissant a permis
de préserver des centaines de milliers
d'emplois en période de fermeture ou de
baisse d'activité avec les nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires
nous avons décidé de poursuivre ce
soutien massif selon les modalités
suivantes pour les entreprises qui sont
totalement fermés comme par exemple les
restaurants les salles de sport ou
encore les discothèques ou qui sont
fermés partiellement comme les commerces
désormais soumis au couvre feu à 18
heures l'état continuera de prendre en
charge 100 % de la rémunération versée
aux salariés
et cela tant que les mesures de
restrictions administratives s'applique
pour les entreprises des secteurs
protégés comme par exemple les hôtels ou
les professionnels de l'événementiel
l'état continuera de prendre en charge
100 % de la rémunération versée aux
salariés jusqu'à fin février à compter
de mars
cette prise en charge à 100 % sera
maintenue pour ceux qui enregistrent une
baisse de 80 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires
pour les autres le reste à charge pour
l'employeur sera de 15 %
enfin pour tous les autres secteurs
l'état continue des laisses de les
soutenir jusqu'à fin février avec un
reste à charge inchangé de 15% pour les
entreprises à compter de mars
ce reste à charge passera à 40 % si les
conditions sanitaires sont réunies
j'invite par ailleurs les entreprises et
des branches professionnelles qui
anticipent des baisses d'activité plus
durable à s'emparer
dispositifs d'activité partielle de
longue durée et à conclure des accords
avec les représentants des salariés
ce dispositif est plus protecteur pour
les salariés et les entreprises que
l'activité partielle de droit commun il
protège l'entreprise le temps que la
situation économique s'améliore
à ce jour plus de 6000 entreprises
représentant huit mille établissements
se sont emparés de ce dispositif
ce sont plus de 420 mille salariés qui
sont ainsi protégés la sauvegarde de
l'emploi est notre priorité et reste
notre priorité jour merci merci beaucoup
madame le ministre
et enfin si j'ose dire roselyne bachelot
monsieur le premier ministre
chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
vous l'avez entendu la situation
sanitaire est extrêmement dégradée et
l'apparition de variant du virus suscite
beaucoup d'inquiétude
c'est en raison de ce contexte épidémie
grave que nous devons sans joie nous
résoudre pour le moment à vivre avec des
lieux culturels fermée au public
musées monuments cinéma salle de
spectacle et avec un couvre feu fixé
maintenant 18 heures
cette fermeture des lieux culturels
n'est pas propre à la france
quasiment tous les pays autour de nous
soumis à la même pression épidémiques
ont pris la même décision
en allemagne les théâtres les cinémas
sont fermés depuis le 2 novembre dernier
les musées depuis le 15 décembre tous
les établissements culturels sont
fermées en autriche en grèce en hongrie
aux pays-bas en pologne en lituanie en
suisse et la liste n'est pas exhaustive
s'il reste quelques territoires où les
théâtres et cinémas restent ouverts ils
se comptent sur les doigts d'une main et
l'évolution de la situation épidémique
les menaces on a par exemple la nouvelle
d'un confinement en portugal qui jusque
là avait échappé à ce défi ions comme
nous l'avons fait depuis le début de la
crise avec constance nous continuerons à
soutenir et à accompagner les acteurs
culturels
jusqu'à ce que les conditions
économiques de fonctionnement soit
restaurée le gouvernement n'a pas failli
et ne faillira pas sur ce front merci
monsieur le premier ministre et monsieur
le ministre de l'économie du maintien
des mesures transversales telles que
vous les avez présenté fonds de
solidarité améliorer exonération des
cotisations sociales prêts garantis par
l'état et par la ministre du travail et
de l'emploi lisabeth bornes activité
partielle dont nos entreprises
culturelles ont largement profité et qui
donc continuer en bénéficier nous
prolongerons également ça c'est très
important pour ce secteur
les dispositifs spécifiques qui ont été
mis en place pour la culture pour chaque
secteur qu'il s'agisse des aides aux
entreprises ou aux personnes fonds de
sauvegarde fonds d'urgence dispositif
d'indemnisation
tout cela sera maintenu avec une
attention particulière sur la
préservation de l'emploi artistique et
culturel et sur les artistes auteurs par
ailleurs nous poursuivons notre travail
d'échangé de concertation avec
l'ensemble des professionnels de la
culture cet enjeu je le partage avec
olivier ferrand pour que nous ne soyons
plus confrontés à chaque inflexion de la
situation sanitaire à un choix binaire
laisser l'établissement ouvert ou fermé
c'est pourquoi avec les professionnels
nous sommes en train de définir un
modèle adaptable qui nous permettent
lorsque nous seront sortis de la phase
aiguë de la crise de pouvoir rouvrir et
progressivement de revenir à un
fonctionnement normal
la tente des professionnels est forte
seuls des publics l'est tout autant
enfin je voudrais rappeler que les
répétitions les tournages les captations
sans public ainsi que l'accueil
d'artistes en résidence reste toujours
possible pour les professionnels
pour l'instant la situation sanitaire
est trop dégradée est trop instable pour
envisager une date ferme de réouverture
mais je sais aussi avec pablo neruda que
le printemps est inexorable merci
beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens face à ce drame que vit
notre pays depuis le monde depuis des
mois et qui pèse sur tant et tant
d'entre nous la priorité des priorités
pour sortir de cette crise elle recours
à la vaccination et nous mettrons toutes
nos forces dans la réussite de ce
programme exceptionnel dans l'ordre et
dans la clarté programme inédit de
vaccination mais nous devons
collectivement faire preuve de patience
et de responsabilité car ce n'est pas
avant plusieurs mois que la vaccination
pourra nous protéger de manière
suffisante
d'ici là nous devons elle a simplement
continué à nous protéger contre le virus
par tous les moyens à notre disposition
l'application stricte des gestes
barrières le port du masque le lavage
des mains le recours au dépistage
au moindre doute et le respect des
consignes d'isolement l'amélioration de
nos prise en charge médicale et le
soutien à nos soignants dont je salue
encore et toujours
l'engagement et la mobilisation de tous
les instants une course de fond est
engagé et je suis persuadé qu'ensemble
nous la gagnons je me tiens à votre
disposition avec les ministres pour
répondre à vos questions
bonsoir frédérique prabonnaud france
télévisions monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez parlé du double intérêt du
vaccin et de sa capacité à limiter la
transmission
je voulais savoir sur quelles données
vous vous fondez pour affirmer ça et
j'avais une deuxième question
pense pas entendu parler de télétravail
je voulais savoir ce qu'ils n'en étaient
qu'à la télé les recommandations
concernant tel travail merci
allez une autre question y apprend que
deux par deux m1 non monsieur morel le
premier ministre je voulais vous avez
avec la ministre de la recherche et des
universités parler de l'ouverture et du
desserrement dans les universités en
revanche est ce que l'on peut considérer
également que les concours et examens
vont également se dérouler normalement
est ce que demain vous avez annoncé une
réunion avec les présidents
d'universités est-ce que vous ce c'est
une réunion de concertation ou est-ce
que vous allez annoncer un plan
d'ouverture des universités concernant
la vaccination
les professionnels de santé demande à
pouvoir vacciner le plus possible
notamment des retraités est ce que cette
vaccination seront ouvertes à l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé qui sont en
capacité de vacciner sur la recherche je
voulais dire vous poser une question
madame vital également il y à une
nouvelle agence anrs maladie épidémique
ou maladies émergentes ont dit qu'elle
n'a pas de financements pérennes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous annoncer
notamment cas l'on n'aura et que ça ne
se fera pas au détriment vous savez que
c'est très important
d'autres pathologies en particulier
évidemment du sida vih
merci alors on va commencer par le mini
60 et évidemment parce que des questions
sur la vaccination ensuite la ministre
viendra j'en profite de temps qu'il
enjoigne pour vous parler de d'un mot
des universités puisque vous nous avez
interrogé sur les perspectives de la
réunion de demain mais c'est d'abord une
réunion de concertation qui a pour
objectif de voir comment les décisions
que nous avions prises avec eux en fin
d'année 2020 se déploie manière
effective de les tester sur les anneaux
ce que j'ai fait ce soir par dans quelle
mesure le monde enseignement supérieur
va s'emparer les mettre en place est
évidemment d'identifier
éventuellement des dispositifs
complémentaires il ne s'agit pas d'un
plan de rouverture à court terme des
universités soyons clairs tout la
situation sanitaire nous incite à la
plus grande prudence
l'objectif c'est à la fois de donner des
perspectives et à court terme de
vraiment voir comment on peut ramener en
présentiel ceux des étudiants qui en ont
absolument besoin pour des raisons
pédagogiques et extra pédagogique la
milice y reviendra monsieur le ministre
trois points fallu deux points et demi
pour répondre à la question vous allez
poser pourquoi est ce qu'ils ont dit que
le vaccin pourrait freiner la
contamination
c'est l'une des questions vous avez posé
le vaccin de pfizer et le vaccin moderna
parce que les premières observations
dans certains pays dans lesquels il ya
eu un certain nombre de personnes déjà
vaccinées
quant à montrer ses les scientifiques de
ces pays aussi qu'ils le disent qu' il y
aurait moins de transmission du virus
est par ailleurs des données publiées
par dans le cadre du vaccin moderna mais
dans le mécanisme est le même que celui
de failles leurs tentes à montrer
qu'effectivement il y aurait une
réduction des contaminations jeu mais
encore évidemment des guillemets vous
connaissez on met des guillemets tant
que tout n'est pas écrit dans le marbre
de la science mais on a des bonnes
raisons d'espérer et j'ai envie de vous
dire que ça fait du bien quant au fait
de savoir que le variant est sensible
aux vaccins ce sont les scientifiques
qui nous le disent sur une base assez
simple qui est que le vaccin cible entre
guillemets sensibilise à une protéine
qui n'est pas concernée par le variant
voc 2020 ni par le variant entre 500 et
7 e re encore une fois je mets des
guillemets mais là aussi on a quand même
quelques bonnes raisons d'espérer
j'en profite pour vous dire que j'ai eu
des chiffres de vaccination du jour
soixante dix mille personnes de plus ont
été protégés aujourd'hui ce qui porte à
3 118 mille le nombre de personnes
vaccinées vous voyez qu'on continue
d'augmenter
pour celles et ceux qui s'inquiétaient
du rythme le rythme est bon et
s'amplifiera encore dans les jours et
semaines à venir
enfin pour la question de pascal morel
sur les professionnels de santé qui
peuvent vacciner j répondu la semaine
dernière
mais je vous le confirme tous les
professionnels de santé même d'ailleurs
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
étudiant et pour un certain nombre
d'entre retraités peuvent être amenés à
vacciner dans les centres de vaccination
ça se passe aujourd'hui dans des centres
lorsque nous aurons d'autres vaccins qui
ne se conserve pas à moins 70 mais plus
sobrement dans un frigo entre 2 et 8
degrés eh bien nous pourrons exploiter
tout le maillage français en pharmacie
en cabinets médicaux pour développer
encore plus et aller encore plus vite
dans des conditions de sécurité
évidemment
madame la ministre recherche
d'enseignement supérieur sur la question
des examens et des concours que vous
avez abordé en fait ils sont pour
certains en train de se tenir
la possibilité est donnée aux
établissements de les organiser à
distance ou désorganisés en présentiel
il ya des disciplines des matières qui
se prête à une évaluation à distance
d'autres qui ne s'y prête pas et donc
c'est des établissements qui organise
cela pour ce qui concerne les examens
nationaux et les concours nationaux
là on est sur les mêmes protocoles qu'à
la sortie du premier confinement c'est à
dire des protocoles sanitaires strictes
et des examens et les concours qui se
déroule en présentiel avec une
organisation qui est pris en charge avec
les établissements et notamment avec
l'inspection générale que je veux
remercier une fois de plus pour pour
cette organisation
effectivement l'agent sa mairesse
reacting a été créée elle a été dotée en
plus des financements de lagence nrs
pour un fonds de départ purement
d'organisation administrative et elle
sera bénéficiaire d'un programme de
recherche spécifique maladies émergentes
dans montant d'environ 50 millions
d'euros que nous sommes en train de
construire avec elle donc voilà ne vous
inquiétez pas il y aura bien un budget
qui ne viendra pas empiéter sur le
budget de la mairesse de l'année
disposer précédemment voilà merci madame
la ministre va j'ai pas évoquer le
télétravail parce qu'en réalité les
règles par rapport à celle que nous
avions décidé en fin d'année n'ont pas
changé donc la ministre va voulais
préciser ou rappelé merci puis après
ministre alors en effet des règles ne
changent pas en matière de télétravail
donc vous savez que depuis fin octobre
nous avons souhaité utiliser au maximum
le télétravail pour réduire les
interactions notamment sur les trajets
domicile travail et en marge du travail
ce qui veut dire qu'un salarié dont la
totalité des tâches peuvent être faites
à distance doit être 100% en télétravail
mais suite aux retours que nous avons eu
des salariés des drh des partenaires
sociaux sur les difficultés qu'éprouve
un certain nombre de salariés qui sont
en télétravail qui était en télétravail
cinq jours sur cinq depuis le début
novembre
nous avons décidé de faire évoluer le
protocole national protocole sanitaire
en entreprise à partir du 7 janvier ce
qui a été fait donc en permettant aux
salariés qui étaient en télétravail à
100% qui en expriment le besoin de
revenir une journée par semaine au
maximum dans l'entreprise donc c'est
cette règle là qui est maintenu merci à
laurent poursuit sur les questions
bonjour bastille auger pour tf1 lci sur
la campagne de vaccination qui commence
à partir de lundi pour toutes les
personnes qui ne peuvent pas se rendre à
un centre de vaccination parce qu'elles
sont chez elles et qu'elles peuvent pas
se déplacer
concrètement qu'est ce qui va être fait
pour elle vous parliez la semaine
dernière monsieur le ministre je crois
de solutions de bus par exemple est ce
que toutes les personnes de plus de 75
ans qui veulent se faire vacciner auront
accès à ce type de solution et puis par
ailleurs vous parliez des publics
fragiles
comment une personne concernée sera si
elle est concernée ou pas par cette
première campagne de vaccination par
exemple est ce que toutes les personnes
diabétiques de tous les âges pourront se
faire vacciner à partir de lundi
prochain
et puis une précision sur les
restrictions il ya bientôt les vacances
de février qui arrivait ce que vous
envisagez de limiter les déplacements de
département en département pour éviter
une circulation du virus qui est ce que
vous recommander aux français ou est-ce
que vous conseiller aux français de
réserver leurs vacances ou est-ce que là
vous leur demander d'attendre merci
notre question et je réponds de l' afp
des élus du grand est où le couvre-feu
prévaut où le couvre-feu à 18h prévaut
depuis quelques jours vous ont alerté ce
matin sur certains effets néfastes comme
l'engagement des grandes surfaces le
samedi matin la saturation des routes
des transports entre 17h et 18h et puis
aussi les conséquences psychologiques
pour les gens dont le quotidien se
réduit peu ou prou au travail
comment comptez faire pour prévenir ou
tout du moins atténuer ses effets là une
question sur la vaccination vous l'avez
dit près de six millions et demi de
personnes sont appelées à se faire
vacciner
et quelle échéance où il espérait les
avoir vacciné et peut-on déduire que
mécaniquement quand ces personnes là
parmi les plus prioritaires seront
vaccinés
des levés de restriction progressive
auront lieu et puis une toute petite
précision sur les travailleurs
frontaliers et dans quelle mesure les
restrictions de déplacement que vous
avez annoncé auront des effets sur ces
travailleurs là notamment avec la suisse
qui est curieux merci alors on prend
moins de questions mi6 et chacun d'entre
vous impose davantage de son ca compte
pas un c'est bon alors que le que le
mini jacente et veuille bien se se
préparer je réponds en ce qui me
concerne au moins deux questions
d'abord vous effectivement j'étais dans
le grand est avec vous monsieur ce matin
où j'ai interrogé enfin en tout cas sur
un département même s'il y avait le
présent de région les élus ça servait à
ça aussi un l'objectif de mon
déplacement n'était pas simplement de
deux visites et l'organisation de la
vaccination là bas mais aussi dans un
département dans une halle
mes rations qui a recours au couvre feu
depuis 18h quels étaient les leurs
impressions leurs sentiments
vous avez en toute transparence entendu
avec moi pour peu qu'il y avait des avis
partagés un certain expliquant que la
mesure était à leurs yeux plutôt
efficaces d'autres et en vendée moins
enthousiastes effectivement ils vont ils
ont bien soulever les questions que nous
connaissions du reste que vous avez
rappelé je les dis vous étiez témoin là
encore j'ai rappelé au préfet du lieu
que notamment s'agissant des personnes
qui se concentrent dans certains grands
centres commerciaux le week-end ou pas
d'ailleurs
enfin le week-end en particulier puisque
ça pourrait être l'un des effets du de
l'avancée de l'horaire du couvre-feu
jeudi je rappelle bruno le maire le sait
parfaitement puisque c'est lui qui les a
négocié avec eux qu'il existe des
protocoles très stricts que il faut à
tout prix faire respecter voilà dans une
grande surface on a calculé desgeorges
il faut mettre quelqu'un à l'entrée qui
compte il y en a qui le font très bien
et quand la georges et la densité sont
atteintes on entre plus sauf si
évidemment ça sort de notre côté donc il
faut que chacun s'astreignent à
respecter cela pour éviter des
phénomènes qui effectivement se
produisent mais qui ne sont pas normaux
bon donc cet échange avec avec les élus
d'autres qu'elle n'ait pas assisté avec
aussi des personnels de santé sur leur
ressenti par rapport à l'effet du
couvre-feu anticipée à 18 heures ont
contribué à nous éclairer ainsi qu'il
vient dans toutes les discussions et
concertations qui avait été conduite
sous l'égide du mise à santé et qui
globalement mais vous l'avez vu nous
sommes plutôt conforté dans le sentiment
qu'il était utile de généraliser cette
mesure
s'agissant autre question mais olivier
aurait pu répondre mais comme on l'a vu
là bas aussi
effectivement il ya la question des
personnes de plus de 75 ans un parti
lundi ou hulu d'âge moindre qui auraient
des difficultés à se rendre dans les
centres de vaccination
v même si elles sont aussi souvent une
famille qui peut les aider à se déplacer
là c'est un peuple qui est clairement
identifié nous avons dit que les acteurs
locaux qui connaissent parfaitement
situation trouve des situations adapté
qui peuvent être je crois que c'est est
évoquée par votre question des
transports
on a aussi entendu parler je ne sais pas
si on l'a dit ce matin c'est sûr qu'on
en a parlé à tarbes samedi afin que les
acteurs locaux nous en parler à table
des équipes mobiles qui pourraient aller
se déplacer au domicile des personnes
concernées je vous le dis je je je fais
absolument toute confiance sous la
coordination du préfet à l'ensemble des
acteurs des territoires pour apporter
les solutions les plus adaptées possible
à chaque situation
il est trop tôt de la question m'a été
posée de dire si on va limiter les
déplacements pour les vacances de
février en particulier je ne comment
dire je ne recommande pas ce soir
d'annuler les réservations pour répondre
très précisément à votre question nous
adapterons faut que j'aille
circonstances mais faut donner une
question précise une réponse claire et
s'agissant des travailleurs frontaliers
je crois que j'ai j'ai donné la réponse
un dôme que nous à avoir des discussions
avec la suisse puisque comme vous l'avez
dit elle est hors union européenne
et s'agissant des travailleurs
frontaliers il y en a là où nous étions
ce matin mais avec des pays dans l'union
j'ai dit qu'évidemment il leur faudrait
un traitement spécifique ou particuliers
et donc pour ceux qui sont internes à
l'union européenne enfin des pays
concernés en tout cas cette question
sera tranchée par le conseil européen de
la semaine prochaine monsieur le
ministre je crois que vous avez répondu
à toutes les questions et ne peut
repartir
ces surnoms mais c'était bon qu'est ce
qu'il y avait d'autres non
oui la liste la liste olivier la liste
parce que ça c'est quand même le
l'annnonce du soir ça ne vous a pas
échappé c'est à dire que quand on a
conscience qu avait dit la presse m'a
fait le le gouvernement a décidé un peu
de de changer le corner qui nous avait
proposé mais une proposition c'est une
proposition c'est nous qui disposons de
ceux des effectifs mans que des
personnes qui présentent certaines
comorbidités comme on dit pardon des
maladies qui les rendent encore plus
fragile au virus il n'y avait pas de
raison qu'elle ne soit pas aussi
prioritaire dans la vaccination
alors maintenant quelles sont ces
pathologies là il vous faut un docteur
ça tombe bien
bon effectivement il y a plusieurs
maladies qui peuvent exposer à des
risques de formes graves de coronavirus
vous en connaissez certaines qui ont
beaucoup moins d'impact d'ailleurs que
l'âge quel que soit l'état de santé plus
on est avancée en âge plus on a de
risques de faire des formes graves
c'est ainsi et donc c'est la haute
autorité de santé professeur fisher qui
ont défini une liste qu'on va dire
d'ultra vulnérables qui va être
communiqué je pense qu'elle va être sur
le site du ministère elle l'est sur le
site du ministère me dit on au ministère
de la santé et des solidarités
et c'est important de se référer à cette
liste parce que il faut que la personne
qui présente cette co morbidités
puissent ensuite aller voir son médecin
qui sur la base du diagnostic pourra lui
donner du délivré une ordonnance en vue
d'être vacciné le diabète ne figure pas
dans la liste mais j'ai cité quelques
pathologies ou quelques situations de
vie qui peuvent exposer à des risques de
forme grave je ne ferai pas toute la
liste complète qui aussi des hémopathies
malignes sous traitement avec
chimiothérapique c'est à dire que je ne
vais pas ici la décliner dans sa
totalité mais l'est elle est facilement
identifiable c'est important ne suffit
pas d'avoir une maladie chronique pour
pouvoir accéder à la vaccination la
semaine prochaine il faut que ce soit
encore une fois corroborée par un
médecin sur la base de ces indications
qui sont définies par les autorités
scientifiques
allez un dernier jeu de questions en
avait pas sur la culture monsieur
premier istres bonsoir mesdames et
messieurs les ministres ont un niveau
d'eau pour europe 1
certains de nos voisins en europe sont
dans des situations sanitaires assez
alarmante et vous sent pas très
alarmiste ce soir on vous avait évoqué
la possibilité d'un confinement si les
choses dérapent aime et on vous sent pas
très alarmiste et puis d'un point de vue
économique
vous avez annoncé de nouvelles nouvelles
mesures très attendues ça ressemble à la
suite du quoi qu'il en coûte comme bien
est-ce que à combien puisque vous
chiffrer ces nouvelles aides
comment est ce que vous les financer et
puis avec monsieur le maire on connaît
évidemment vos goûts vos principes sur
la rigueur budgétaire que vous n'avez
pas des sueurs froides quand vous
énoncez tous ces chiffres
allez une dernière question bonsoir luc
besson bfm tv sur les écoles d'abord on
a entendu le président du conseil
scientifique être très inquiet de
l'arrivée de ces variants est appelée à
la commenter la vigilance notamment dans
les écoles en quoi les règles sanitaires
vont être durcies vous avez parlé des
tests 1 millions par semaine mais
concrètement quels seront les moyens à
déployer pour ça et puis un mot sur la
culture parce qu'on en a pas parlé dans
les questions est ce qu'il y à certains
types de salles cinéma théâtre qui
pourront ouvrir avant d'autres quid des
musées est ce qu'il y à un critère quel
est votre critère finalement sanitaire
une donnée qui pourrait vous permettre
de décider enfin de les rouvrir ou est
ce qu'on peut dire clairement il faut
attendre d'avoir vacciné
le gros des français merci bien je
demande peut-être au ministre de
l'économie de se préparer je vais pas
votre première toutes leurs questions
qui effectivement importantes d'abord je
ne suis jamais alarmiste d'accord
alarmiste je suis vigilant toujours
depuis le début
on va dire je je ne crois pas avoir la
réputation de mollir lorsqu'il faut
prendre des décisions
d'accord quelle qu'en soit la difficulté
compris politiques
je pense avoir toujours privilégié le
critère sanitaires sur toute autre
considération
vous avez raison de dire que la
situation en europe est difficile dans
certains pays
dramatique dramatique vous en connaissez
les raisons je vais pas vous les voulez
rappelé donc j'essaie à la fois nous
essayons d'analyser avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement et en particulier ministre
chargé de la santé la situation
épidémique en france actuelle est
projeté actuelle est projetée et donc
comme je l'aï indiqué dans mon propos
nous avons des indicateurs
épidémiologique qui à ce jour aurait
rendu sans doute excessif en confinement
sont quand même expliqué je peux pas
venir vous expliquer un jour que je re
consignes tout le pays chauds à base de
tels critères vous ne manqueriez pas de
me faire observer que ces critères ne
soit absolument pas réunies si j'avais
fait l inverse est donc en réalité comme
je les dis ce soir les mesures de
durcissement que nous avons prises qui
sont réelles qui certes ne vont pas
jusqu'au confinement elle s'explique par
le fait donc que les chiffres pour être
un peu meilleure que dans les autres
pays ne sont pas non plus
exceptionnellement bon ben c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
et puis surtout pour tenir compte de cet
environnement de ceux de ses virées
virus variant voilà il faut se préparer
et ce sera un moment le dernier élément
de réponse
voilà je loue suivant la situation au
jour le jour je crois que nous avons
d'ailleurs amélioré et nous serons mal à
nous parce que nous le monde entier les
outils de suivi de la crise pour être en
capacité de réagir dès que possible
c'est toujours vous savez un dosage
l'équilibré recherché extrêmement
difficile voilà ça nous amène à la
question où ça nous ramène à la question
sur l'école c'est à dire que vous voyez
bien que je les dis le critère sanitaire
est le premier des critères
mais il se peut qu'arriver à fermer ou à
confiner le dit devant des médecins qui
est aussi des conséquences sanitaires
psychologiques et c'est donc cette série
de paramètres que nous devons utiliser
pour expliquer à nos concitoyens le
fondement de décision le fait qu'elle
soit difficile à prendre
oui nous savons depuis un moment mais il
faut qu'elle soit adaptée aux
circonstances
c'est comme ça qu'elles seront le mieux
comprises et je laisse faire le mieux
acceptée d'où l'idée pardon ce qui me
fait passer la balle à mon voisin
bien que ceux qui sont impactés par les
mesures comprend et ne doutait pas qu'il
y aura un impact de l'avancement du
couvre-feu à 18 heures n'en doutez pas
d'ailleurs s'il y avait aucun impact sur
le prendrais pas il vient il faut aussi
qu'ils bénéficient de la solidarité
nationale est gardé par l'état pour
répondre précisément vos questions
d'abord combien ce que coûtent les
mesures que nous venons d'annoncer ses 4
milliards d'euros par mois
l'augmentation du fonds de solidarité
les exonérations de charges la prise en
charge des coûts fixes notamment pour
les louer ces 4 milliards d'euros
mensuels n'inclut pas les coûts liés à
l'activité partielle est uniquement les
coûts liés aux mesures que j'ai annoncée
est-ce que nous avons les moyens
financiers de supporter ces dépenses
supplémentaires la réponse est oui parce
que nous avons été prévoyants nous avons
à la fois dégager des moyens
supplémentaires pour 2021 et nous aurons
aussi j'aurai l'occasion de le préciser
la semaine prochaine avec le ministre
les comptes publics
olivier du soft le report de dépenses
qui n'ont pas été effectuées en 2020
prenez l'exemple du confinement
en novembre nous ont perdu 12%
d'activités là nous avions perdu 30 pour
son activité au 1er confinement donc
nous avons des reports de dépenses qui
n'ont pas été effectués par ce que
l'impact du deuxième confinement sur
l'activité économique a été moins
or que celui du premier alors même que
nous avions prévu un impact aussi fort
troisième question est ce que c'est le
bon choix stratégique je vais vous
répéter ce que nous répétons aux
prémices et le présent la république
depuis le début d'abord c'est le choix
qu'ont fait tous les états européens
et c'est un choix de justice et de
raisons de justice parce qu'aucun de ces
restaurateurs de seebach de ses hôtels
de ses salles de sport de ses salles de
spectacles de culture n'a demandé à
fermer ils sont victimes des règles
sanitaires
donc il est juste que nous les
soutenions est ce que c'est le bon choix
économique oui parce que nous protégeons
des compétences et nous protégeons des
entreprises et cela garantit ensuite la
relance économique la plus rapide
possible
si vous voulez relancer l'économie mais
qui a plus d'entreprise et qui a plus de
salariés pour faire tourner les
entreprises que vous n'allez pas aller
très loin
enfin quatrième question est ce que
cette augmentation de la dette publique
liés à ces dépenses supplémentaires
devra être remboursé la réponse est oui
je le redis tous ceux qui prétendent qu
on ne rembourse pas sa dette tiennent
des propos qui sont irresponsables
il faudra rembourser cette dette il
faudra le faire le moment venu
c'est-à-dire une fois que la crise
sanitaire sera derrière nous le faire
avant ce serait risquer de tuer dans
l'oeuf la reprise et sur la base d'une
stratégie que je proposerai au premier
ministre et au président de la
république en tenant le plus grand
compte des recommandations de la
commission que le prix mini sera mis en
place et qui est présidée par jean
arthuis
merci j'invite misé kassian nationale à
venir pendant qu'il arrive permettent
d'ajouter deux choses
compte tenu la réponse précise with
économique enfin je sais que vous en
êtes convaincu mais si on ne faisait pas
cela combien de drames humains
combien de drames
quel coût économique aussi quels coûts
économiques et payer tous ces gens là
seraient au chômage dans des situations
dramatiques donc ça a un coût dont il ya
enfin ce que c'est c'est un choix qui
nous honore un choix qui nous honore et
deuxième chose que je vais vous dire
par rapport à votre question c'est que
je parlait d' équilibre on va dire que
on peut être certainement pas alarmiste
très vigilant très inquiets on peut dire
aussi en toute lucidité que ce deuxième
confinement
finalement il a produit des résultats
sanitaires dont l'ensemble des
commentateurs considèrent qu'ils sont
plutôt satisfaisants au sein de l'union
européenne et par rapport à nos voisins
s'en sent comme bruno le maire l'a
rappelé faire s'effondrer complètement
l'économie
elle s'est même - effondré que nous ne
l'aurions prévu du coup elle coûtera
moins aux finances publiques par rapport
à votre question ce deuxième confinement
que nous ne l'avions anticipé est
budgétée et donc ça nous redonne un peu
de marge pour faire face aux cela donc
ça veut dire que tout ça a été très
difficile je pense à tous ces
commerçants qu'on a fermé les acteurs de
la culture on y revient c'est à tout ça
est dramatique mais on avait là aussi
trouver un équilibre entre les
impératifs sanitaires qui sont toujours
en premier et aussi le maintien de
l'activité économique et social l'autre
priorité je le martèle l'école
l'éducation l'école l'éducation est là
aussi en termes relatifs monsieur le
ministre nous tenons le choc mais il
faut être là aussi vigilant voudrait
parfaitement raison mais bien sûr sur
l'école ce que l'on peut dire d'abord
c'est que au moment du départ en
vacances de noël
on avait un taux que l'on avait calculé
sur les lycées qui était de 0 3% sur la
base justement des campagnes de tests
que nous avons fait en décembre
cette ce taux nous permettait de dire
que l'épidémie était sous contrôle si on
peut dire dans le milieu scolaire
c'est vrai que depuis lors l'élément
nouveau selvaria anglais et les craintes
que l'on a dans l'ensemble de la société
comme dans le milieu scolaire sur ce que
cela pourrait signifier en termes de
contagiosité
depuis c'est à dire depuis le retour des
vacances de noël
nous regardons évidemment comme nous le
faisions avant jour par jour les
contaminations qui existe dans le milieu
scolaire
ce que nous observons c'est une courbe
qui ressemble exactement la coupe que
nous avions retour des vacances de la
toussaint
cette courbe donc est une courbe qui est
un peu comme une cloche alors on est au
sommet de la cloche actuellement sa des
retours de 2000 à 3000 contamination
déclaré par jour je rappelle que ce
chiffre est forcément sous-estimé par
rapport aux données réelles puisque nous
avons deux courbes la courbe des
déclarations tous les jours de
contamination et puis la courbe de santé
publique france qui est ce que les
administrations de la santé peuvent
recueillir grâce aux données
personnelles sur la santé et l'intérêt
c'est d'avoir c'est de voir ces deux
courbes qui suivent tendance parallèle
le fait que ça augmente peu de temps
après les vacances nous indique surtout
que c'est pendant les vacances que des
contaminations ont lieu chez des enfants
ce qui au passage souligner que
lorsqu'on dit que les enfants ne
devraient pas être à l'école ça veut
dire qu'on l'aimé ailleurs et quand dans
cet ailleurs très souvent ils
contaminent davantage
rappelons le aussi évidemment c'est un
argument supplémentaire pour ne pas
fermer les échos
l'argument principal étant évidemment
celui dit par le premier ministre c'est
à dire que l'éducation c'est pas une
variable d'ajustement l'éducation c'est
pas quelque chose de marginal
d'éducation c'est fondamental pour
chaque enfant de france et du monde
d'ailleurs donc cette courbe lula nous
la suivons est évidemment de manière
quotidienne et bien entendu si elle
devait monter très haut elles nous
amèneraient à prendre des mesures plus
restrictives encore mais pour l'instant
nous considérons qu on est sur des
chiffres qui sont finalement comparable
à ce que nous avions au début du pendant
la première quinzaine du mois de
novembre
ensuite est-ce que les mesures et c'est
la deuxième partie de vos questions sont
adaptés à cette à cette situation
au fond nous avons des points de
fragilité dans la vie quotidienne de nos
élèves
premier point de fragilité c'est la
cantine évidemment c'est évident et
évidemment la solution de facilité ce
serait fermée les cantines mais là aussi
nous aurions des inconvénients qui
serait probablement supérieurs aux
avantages
rappelons que lorsqu'on était en
confinement en mars avril et qu' il ya
eu le retour au mois de mai il y avait
des pétitions parfois pour ouvrir les
cantines même sans ouvrir les écoles
tant les inconvénients socio éducatif
même est tout simplement les en termes
d'alimentation quotidienne des enfants
poser des problèmes du fait de cette
fermeture donc la cantine c'est
important aussi ça ne se sacrifient pas
comme ça et donc nous la meuse et des
mesures que nous prenons ce sont
simplement des mesures d'encadrement
plus rigoureuse de la cantine parfois
cela peut aller dans certains envois
jusqu'à la fermeture de la cantine quand
on n'arrive pas à remplir ces conditions
strictes c'est un sujet de dialogue
quotidien avec les collectivités locales
qui sont en responsabilité sur ce point
les autres mesures que nous prenons sont
des mesures qui sont faites pour
toujours plus limité les brassages
c'est le cas notamment de l'hybridation
en lycée et beaucoup plus rarement en
collège et puis l'autre mesure
évidemment c'est en matière de
d'éducation physique et sportive on sait
là aussi c'est parfaitement démontré que
l'activité de manger d'une part
l'activité souffle et d'autre part et
d'enlever son masque tout simplement
conduisent éventuellement à des
contaminations
c'est évidemment la mort dans l'âme que
nous supprimons cette activité j'ai
utilisé le mot suspendre parce qu'encore
une fois nous avons des protocoles
sanitaires strictes sport par sport
domaine par domaine et j'espère bien
qu'on pourra ré ouvrir parce que là
aussi l'activité physique des enfants
ça n'est pas négligeable je t'ai
conscience aussi à la créativité de
toussaint les activités physiques de
plein air reste possible bien entendu
espérons que la météo permettra qu'elle
soit effective est en tout cas c'est
dans ce sens que nous travaillons merci
beaucoup je vous propose pour répondre à
dernière question dans la vigne et
culture on ne prend plus de questions et
réponses le premier ministre pour
répondre et donner de la visibilité il
faut tenir compte du fait par dont il
faut tenir compte du fait que la
situation sanitaire laden sanitaire a
profondément changé avec l'apparition
des variants et de leur pouvoir de
contamination changer accéléré telle que
la décrit olivier ferrand nous
travaillons donc dans deux directions
d'abord nous avons renforcé nos liens
avec le ministère de la santé pour
approfondir et solidifier nos
connaissances sur sur tous ces sujets
nous avons des groupes de travail un
gros
de travail en commun avec olivier véran
pour regarder l'impact de la
contamination des contaminations dans
les lieux dans les lieux de culture
nous regardons également dans ce cadre
avec beaucoup d'attention des
expérimentations qui sont menées je
pense à l'expérimentation barcelone par
exemple ou de leipzig et nous avons deux
organisations qui vont mener des
expérimentations
le syndicat des musiques actuelles avec
l'inserm et le prodiss avec l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris pour regarder
que ce qui se passe dans les lieux de
culture
avec cette nouvelle donne sanitaire qui
est la nôtre on voit que les conditions
qui ont été posées dans ses
expérimentations sont des conditions
extrêmement strictes comme par exemple
l'obligation de par un test pcr de
conditionner ainsi l'entrée dans les
salles de spectacle ou également les
questions de ventilation de température
de port d'un masque ffp2 et de
conditions de sécurité extrêmement forte
qui pose un certain nombre de problèmes
de généralisation au secteur c'est donc
le deuxième axe qui est le nôtre dans
les lieux de culture c'est de travailler
avec les acteurs de la culture à un
modèle résilient nous avons d'ailleurs
commencé ce travail ce dès avant noël
sous votre égide monsieur le premier
ministre je dois dire que le monde de la
culture est extrêmement facilitateur
dans ce domaine est prêt à accepter des
conditions très strictes au niveau des
jauges au niveau des distances au niveau
des conditions d'en tisser psy est
effectivement souhaite aussi se
développer dans la dans le cadre de la
procédure tout senti que vides ça aussi
avec des qr codes qui permettrait s'il y
avait une contamination de retrouver à
proximité les gens qui pourraient être
contaminés donc nous travaillons donc
dans ces deux directions la recherche
scientifique la solidification des
données scientifiques pour garantir la
sécurité des personnes
et de nouvelles conditions de
fréquentation des salles en tout cas ce
que je peux dire c'est qu'effectivement
à calendrier glissant pourraient être
faits dans ce domaine qui pourrait
permettre une réouverture échelonné des
lieux de culture en fonction des données
scientifiques spécifiques à chacun de
ces lieux de culture
merci beaucoup à l'épaule pareil à tous
je
ce que ça
on